[Music]
businesses are reopening all around the
world so oil prices are starting to
rebound the coronavirus and lockdown
plus an oversupply of crude had forced a
record drop in prices last month price
of gasoline at the pump also fell too
much crude oil means that some of it is
sitting in tankers off the California
coast look at that Carter Evans looks
now at the offshore traffic jam and what
it will take to unload all that oil oil
tankers in the waters surrounding
America's largest port complex have
turned this patch of Pacific into a
floating parking lot on this day 27
tankers some carrying up to a million
barrels of unrefined oils at idle this
is roughly tripled the normal number
that we would have when the port complex
is on a normal day captain kit looted
monitors port traffic for the marine
exchange of Southern California there's
generally a population of 3 to 5 tankers
out there waiting to come in but you
usually move them through pretty quickly
correct because there's demand which is
what we're lacking now correct wide open
because of the stay at home orders
demand for gas has plummeted leading to
a backup in the global supply chain all
those ships are out there because we
don't have anywhere in California to put
their oil we have filled all of the
storage tanks of refining as all
California but there's no more space
professor roger shaggy is an oil
industry analyst at the University of
Southern California with some refineries
already shut down he fears what will
happen when cars are back on the road
and give me the increases all of a
sudden go up and II don't have the
refinery operation you don't have the
capacity well you don't have shortages
you're gonna have gas lines forming in
the gas station as we did in 73 m79 at
some point we're gonna wish we had more
ships out there that's right you're
gonna cost money to keep this tankers
floating offshore but somebody's gonna
pay for that it's gonna be you and I
when we put the gas in the tank exactly
but you just hope if they have to stay
here 1 months 2 months 3 months
nothing's going to happen to that did
you see anything really interesting
while you were out there u.s. Coast
Guard captain Rebecca or will soon take
command of the sector that includes this
massive port we're making sure that
chips are where they're supposed to be
for monitoring these things on radar as
well as voice communications and just
looking for anything unusual
the tankers all have double walled hulls
reducing the danger of an oil spill and
although it looks crowded out here or
says only about half of the parking
spaces are occupied so we have lots of
room for these ships but I think about
it these are it could be good terrorist
targets out here sure so the Anchorage's
all around us are still open to
recreational vessel traffic if we do
aviation patrol from a helicopter we can
see if there's anything that looks
unusual the perspective from the water
really gives you an idea of how big
these oil tankers are but one of the
best views of all of these ships is
actually from a room back onshore it's
the marine equivalent of an air traffic
control tower we keep them from bumping
into each other by watching them on our
screens just like there are traffic
lanes on the road there are traffic
lanes in the ocean the ships all have
them how long could they end up being
here we have information that one may be
there as long as the beginning of July
the beginning of July yes part of
California's economy will start
reopening Friday and that will boost
demand for gas but it will take weeks to
clear this traffic jam meaning it could
be a long summer for the men and women
patrolling these waters for CBS this
morning Carter Evans in the Port of Los
Angeles oil everywhere Carter thank you
very much it's incredible pictures there